- Yes.
- Ah, get there.
- Ah, Eureka, I found it.
- You what?
- Eureka, my gnomon.
- Eureka, gnomon, it's pure nonsense.
- Nonsense, Eureka, that means I found it.
And the gnomon is a research instrument.
- Well, it's all Greek to me.
- Precisely.
- I'm right?
- Yes, it's ancient Greek.
Right so, that's what it is.
- That's no research instrument, what do you call it?
It's only a lousy little stick.
But with this little stick, the Greeks measured the whole Earth.
Ah, measured the Earth with a stick?
Yes.
Hmm, that must have taken them quite a long while.
That stick's pretty small.
Well, they didn't lay it end to end.
The Greeks had great ideas, intuition.
Our civilization owes everything to them.
Yes, well, almost everything.
The Greek era was an extraordinary one in the history of human civilization.
Just think.
The sciences, the arts, philosophy.
They rose to heights 2,000 years past before there was really anything new.
2,000 years realized.
Pythagoras applied mathematics to every area of human knowledge.
Hippocrates founded medicine.
Yes, back then.
And Socrates' philosophy.
Know thyself.
If you don't know yourself, you don't know anything.
Know that you know everything if you know that you know nothing.
Yes, and Phileas breathes life into stone.
Athena, 60 feet high.
Sophocles and Euripides writing immortal masterpieces for the theater.
Oh, yes. For Protagoras, man is already the reference for all things.
For Anaxagoras, intelligence is the guiding principle in the world.
And Democritus found the atom. How long ago?
Twenty centuries. It's fantastic.
The atom?
Oh, 2,400 years ago.
No way, not true.
Yes, I thought that might surprise you all.
Now, I'm going to tell you about Democritus.
We don't know much about him except that he was always laughing.
Hmm. No, you're wrong. The world's not made of four elements.
But there's only fire, water, air, and earth.
And what if there were different states of the same element?
Watch this. See the effect of the heat? The water evaporates.
And it's transformed into what? Into air.
What about fire?
Oh, this branches from the earth.
And it's transformed into fire.
No, there are not four elements.
There is one fundamental element, the smallest that can exist.
Hm? Here, look at this.
Even a grain of sand isn't the smallest thing on Earth, because we can crush it into pieces.
No, the smallest thing is an atom.
So small, we can't even see them.
I'm gonna smash it and make an atom.
Ha ha ha, go on, try it.
You can make it smaller still.
You think so, even smaller?
Right.
Maybe in the future, people may learn how to see atoms, but not in our time.
All we can do is imagine them.
So it was, Democritus conceived a battle 2,400 years before modern physicists were able to see them.
And the gnomon, a piece of wood?
Yeah, the gnomon.
You'd be surprised at all the things it'll do. Look at this.
With the gnomon's shadow, you can tell time it's a sundial.
Standing up, it becomes a vertical line. Lying down, it's horizontal.
Together, they make a right angle.
The gnomon can point to the north, to the west, to the east, to the south.
The gnomon's shadow lets us determine the height of any object, no matter how tall.
this pyramid is 250 feet high but you said that we could measure the whole
earth with that stick we give us no no way it's all a big lie it's true measure
the earth it's simple you just had to think of it
eratosthenes figured out eratosthenes about 250 years before our era it
happened on the 21st of June at Siena Egypt today precisely at noon the Sun
will be directly above right over our heads lighting up the bottom of the
Well, that means a gnomon won't cast a shadow.
The sun will be straight up vertical.
And I will measure the size of the earth.
How are you going to do that?
You'll see.
Look, the gnomon's shadow is getting shorter.
The sun is precisely over our heads.
Now look, over here.
There we are, that's all.
Yes, so?
So you'll see, we're going to Alexandria.
Greetings to you.
I did exactly what you asked.
At noon, precisely on the day you said,
the gnomon's shadow reached exactly this far.
Right here.
There, you see?
At Cien, there was no shadow, so the sun was directly overhead, vertical.
Here at Alexandria, the gnomon casts this shadow.
We know the distance between Cien and Alexandria.
By extending the circle, we can calculate the Earth's circumference.
So the Earth's circumference is, uh, 252,000 stadiums.
You sure about that?
Oh, yes, absolutely sure.
Do you realize, children, what science, what precision?
Such intuition, 252,000 stadiums.
What's a stadium?
the length of the running track used in the olympics 252 000 stadiums that comes to exactly
39 690 kilometers only 300 kilometers off the mark with a no man just an ordinary little stick
syracuse in sicily had been under greek control for a long time in the third century before our
era it had already become a rich and powerful city-state with half a million people living in
Father!
Archimedes!
Mother!
Back at last, I was worried.
There is no need, Mother.
Alexandria is a peaceful city, and I studied with Euclid, the greatest mathematician in the world.
Did you work well?
I think so.
Euclid was pleased with me, and I have an idea.
I think I have a way of squaring the circle.
You mean you can square the circle?
The problem that's eluded all scholars?
Come, my lad.
You'll see, Father, I will.
In the meantime, I'll introduce you to the king.
He may be of some help, do you?
Phidias, court astronomer, and his son, Archimedes, request an audience with his majesty, the king.
Yes, come forward, come forward.
Well, Phidias, I see your son, Archimedes, is back from Alexandria?
Yes, majesty, your peers have learned much.
And did he have to go such a long way?
Here in Syracuse, haven't we good teachers?
Yes, your majesty, but the greatest of them all, Euclid, teaches in Alexandria.
Very well, Archimedes, I'll give you the occasion to prove your knowledge.
come here my goldsmith has made this crown for me in solid gold or so he says i suspect he's
being economical with the truth might he not somehow have put into it a less noble metal
a less precious one in your opinion do you think we can know without in any way damaging the crown
go on akimedes i am listening there is no way you'd have to break the crown what a shame such
a beautiful object i haven't asked your advice namatos i wonder if you aren't in league with
goldsmith in this. Well, Archimedes, demonstrate your reasoning power. I'll try, your majesty.
I'll require a little time. Do you need one day or will it take two? Two days will do, your majesty.
You'd better find an answer. How will you do it? I'll have to calculate the crown's volume.
Then, by weighing it, I'll be able to say if its weight corresponds to that of gold,
a very heavy metal. Calculate its volume or you're dreaming. Its shape is irregular and
ornamental it's impossible i'll think about it father hmm well while you think about it let's go
to the bathroom help us relax good idea i mean he's go like that the back to idea just said recon
found it didn't find it was nothing is running naked in the streets a new sport that's our
comedian finis's son you mean the genius is the crown really made of pure gold yes of course to
To make it, I melted down 60 pieces of gold.
Order 60 gold pieces to be brought here, your majesty.
Notice the weight of its volume in water that overflowed.
Pieces.
One, two, three, sixty-nine.
60 pieces.
Yes, the weight of 60 pieces of gold is the same as that of the crown.
But the water level has not gone to the top.
Which demonstrates that the gold has less volume than the crown.
And so the crown is not made of pure gold.
It contains another metal that's lighter.
You sure of what you say?
Yes, sire, I am.
How come this is a fraud?
Sixty pieces of pure gold made that crown.
We just waited.
Yes, it's the same weight.
But the density is different.
That means the crown contains another lighter metal.
Look here.
Watch.
You'll see what I mean.
You see, the weight is the same, but the cushion is much larger.
It's made of matter less dense than gold.
Justy, I assure you, I'm as honest as the day is long.
I'd never dare to...
There is a way to verify it.
And what's that?
Bring a sledgehammer.
Watch your step.
You'd better be sure of yourself.
My crown is pure gold and you destroy it.
Then, Majesty, you may chop off my hand.
Swindler or an idiot, don't care which.
Put your learning to use, Archimedes.
You will be of benefit to our people.
To make it easier.
Have you any ideas, Archimedes?
Quite a simple one.
An endless screw.
The blades are turned by the current in the river.
Water rises and comes out the top.
It requires neither man nor beast of power to turn the water real.
No, Majesty.
Cedarwood, wish it was a level of river range.
There ought to be a way to make this work easier.
Yes, Majesty. I could lift this ship with one hand if it were to run aground.
What did you say? What did you say?
Surely you're exaggerating, Archimedes.
No, I can do it.
You said it, Majesty. He said he could lift this ship using only one hand. Let's do it.
Well, Archimedes, you mean what you say?
Yes.
One hand.
Well, we shall see.
That's right. We shall see.
King's orders, you are to beach this ship on the sand over there!
Go do it!
In your place, I wouldn't count my chickens this year.
Yes, majesty, but lift it with one hand!
He's famous.
People realized that science wasn't a hobby.
Ah, it could be applied to all areas of daily life.
Comedians once said, "Give me a fulcrum, and with my lever I will lift the world."
Really, the lever has to be strong enough, huh?
Let me tell you about another time when our comedians used his science.
Less spectacular than lifting a ship or determining how much gold is in a crown,
but still it was a remarkable achievement.
Really extraordinary.
That, even today, scientists admire.
The squaring of the circle.
- What of the what? - Squaring the circle.
You'll see, it's not very complicated.
A square calculating its surface area is simple, right?
- Oh, yeah, sure. - It's easy.
But to work out the area of a circle, what do you do?
The radius squared multiplied by 3.1416.
Quite right, correct.
An easy formula to say, but not so easy to discover.
And demonstrate, and that Archimedes achieved.
The area of a circle is somewhere between a square surrounding it and a square contained within it.
Once he had demonstrated this, he went on to find the formula we just heard.
The magic number 3.1416.
But back to Archimedes.
Archimedes, I'm going to die.
Just when Rome threatens my grandson, Hieronymus, is young, without experience.
You are a man of science, of wisdom, I ask you.
Help him, counsel him, the young king.
I'll do all I can, Majesty.
We have been victorious everywhere in Sicily.
And now, Marcellus.
Legions march on Syracuse.
This city is a rich, magnificent trophy.
Assassinated.
Marcellus is bearing down on Syracuse with his fleet and war machines.
We must be ready to fight, Archimedes.
But General, I know nothing about war.
You are a great scholar.
You have designed magnificent war machines.
Now is the time for us to build them for our defense.
All right, we'll do it.
Assemble all able-bodied men.
I'll need carpenters, stone cutters, tanners, rope makers, blacksmiths.
500 men to practice archery, harbor our ships in a safe place,
reinforce all fortifications at the port, and block the entrance.
Build up stocks of wheat, oil, cattle.
Anybody to see you. From Syracuse. He says he's important.
Cinnamon. This is spared. I want him alive. Great man.
Just a moment, but there's a little problem that I, uh...
was a great inventor and alas suffered a tragic end you'll see the Greeks haven't said their last
word they created so many great inventions that I'll tell you about oh yes you'll see you'll see